Today is google developer relations Suzuki
Thank you for coming to Atsushi Nakano of gd of google app of 8 gd today
Do you want to hear the story in various ways?
Apis responsible for chess gd
We say Nakamura 3
Wrong
Up once from around 2010 4
Beginning to use
So especially about club grab script
Do talks and study sessions
Something like writing news or something like that from around 2010
I saw it
Did you buy it for the opportunity to start?
That's in the Google App called spreadsheet lost on google io
In the application of documentation
I have a spreadsheet, but the system of the script is included in it
The good thing is that in the beginning of 2009 I don't know much about it
The
The fact is that various data when I was touching that little bit when it was 2010
You can access to
Knowing that it will be automated, this is a routine work you usually do
Tally something
If you exceed that certain threshold you have to send some notification
In that time, it would be possible to automate everything that human beings are making decisions
Well various details from
I'm starting to write a script
Banquet satipet that is said to be moving every day
Mama 惜 island Jean There may be a sound that can not be a job, but how about yellow people
Increase usage
The easiest to understand in many cases is that the remaining capacity management device of the disk
For example, if there is a lot of storage for that file, which disk is which
It is difficult to understand whether it is used only before
Only the remaining balance is registered in the splash, and the remaining capacity is
For example, you can set a key value that cuts 10% keel or 20% and email it only when kicking it
If you put out
Then human beings have something to do with the capacity there since the mail came
Suddenly 99 parts become 100% and can not write because there is no need to work out that plan
I think it often happens to notice it, but all that can be avoided
Conversely, as I mentioned earlier, that kind of server migration style is used
Besides, there are many places that drink sake in the community as gd
I think that it will be designated as a park or something, but whatever the form is exactly
this
This is a good idea to study Google Apps Gift
What kind of advice do you want people to start?
Who's using and more Fiday routing
I think it will be useful that
There are people who think that I'm looking for two kinds of pulling like that one lump
That person is usually that way
I have touched spreadsheet software like excel, but
I'm all done
Speaking of people in a team
In dealing with that spreadsheet
The place where children can do it already seems to be script script but how is it?
So much skill that it's skill doesn't detail me
Even for those who say that Google App Script
Help is also substantial because the threshold of is low
That's why I want you to use it first and the other is that
The people who are the stations of bali bali engines are already
Because I can do a part without reading the document, I am a person from the same company
Among people in the same community
For example, I want to mail one of 1002 barbers
When I say, I think I'm not so detailed, but I think it's 100 deep
Instead of using that script, if you actually write 10 seconds of employee sales, it will fall apart
I can do something like merge printing, so that's a bit more of that 3
I would like people to write off for a place
There are roughly two such alternatives.
I think that the talk of the community came out earlier
I think it is done in the form of a manager in the community.
What kind of activities do we do in the community and now? Most of them
The story of is that
It is gas now of exhaust gas
I want to do something like this but I can't even
That's that of the brain
Questions and answers but most of the answers are another Mr. Ohashi called g yes
Well then bang bang
That's the answer to that faq or in Japanese that much of that failure story
Since it does not go up to the net mountain, using the community to mail basis Solos
Josiah prepared
Some advice for those who want to know that you want to have a former bus you want to marry
It sounds like
What
For everyone who uses Google Apps
In fact, it doesn't mean that the other party really has to be something, so for now
There is a sense of not only using but also trying to make better use of it
If
By all means always with the community of google apis Japan
Have you look at the flow
If you don't understand, it won't be interesting anymore.
I think the leader Yes thank you for today